اتفق المشاركون في قمه القاهره لدول
الجوار السوداني على تشكيل اليه وزاريه
مهمتها وضع خطه عمل لوقف الاغتسال بين
اطراف الصراع والتوصل عبر تفوض الى حل
شامل للازمه السودانيه وشددت توصيات القمه
على عدم التدخل في الازمه والتعامل معها
بوصفها شانا داخليا وذلك بالتكامل مع
الاليات القائمه لدى ايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
دلاله تعدد المنصات الافريقيه بين الايجاد
والاتحاد الافريقي
من تباين الرؤى والمواقف المنبثقه عنها
واي مواقف للاطراف السودانيه من ذلك
التباين
ومنع كاسات تضارب المواقف والمصالح بين
دول الجوار السوداني وما اهداف هذه الدول
الاستراتيجيه في تعاملها مع الازمه
وتداعيتها
وما مستقبل الازمه وسيقاتها الانسانيه
والسياسيه في ضوء المواقف المعلنه لدول
الجوار وتاثيرها المباشر على المعطيات على
الارض
[موسيقى]
قمه في القاهره لدول الجوار السوداني مهدت
لها جلسه تحضيريه انتهت الى مخرجات
استبقها حديث عن تباين بين الدول المشاركه
في الرؤى والمصالح مخرجات اكدت على اهميه
عدم التدخل الخارجي في الازمه السودانيه
خشيه ان يعرقل جهود احتوائها ويطيل من
امدها القمه شددت كذلك على وحده السودان
وسيادته واستقراره باعتباره او باعتبار
ذلك حاجزا دون التداعيات السلبيه المحتمله
للازمه على دول الجوار كان الرئيس المصري
والرئيس الارتري والرئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي
قد اكدوا بمناسبه القمه على ان السودان
يمر بازمه عميقه
لها تداعياتها السلبيه على الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه والعالم وتدعم
السريع رحبت كذلك بمخرجات قمه القاهره
وكذلك فعل مجلس السياده السوداني الذي
اعرب عن استعداده لوقف اطلاق النار في حال
التزمت قوات الدعم بذلك كان نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده فرحان حق
كان قد اكد ان اي حل للازمه السودانيه يجب
ان ياخذ بالاعتبار دول الجوار
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس
الاستاذ محمد تورشين الكاتب والباحث
السياسيه السوداني ومن القاهره الاستاذ
عطيه عيسوي الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه
ومن اديس ابابا السيد محمد العروسي عضو
البرلمان الفيدرالي الاثيوبي مرحبا بكم
جميع وسؤالنا الاستاذ عطيه عيسوي استاذ
عطيه مرحبا بك في البدايه كانت قبل قمه
القاهره كانت هناك منصات عديده تتعامل مع
الازمه في السودان ايجاد الاتحاد الافريقي
المبعوث الاممي كل منها كانت له مشكلته مع
احد او طرفي النزاع داخل السودان ما الذي
سعت اليه قمه القاهره ونجحت او لم تنجح
فيه بحيث توحد هذه الرؤى وتخرج بمخرجات
جديده يمكن ان ينبني عليها حل لهذا الصراع
اهلا وسهلا
المحاولات والمبادرات السابقه ايا كانت
اطرافها كلها كانت جاده ربما كان بعضها
متسرعا ولم ياخذ كل الابعاد في الحسبان
ولكن كانت هناك محاولات جاده
ومصره
ومتميزه مثل المحاولات التي بذلتها
السعوديه والولايات المتحده
لحل الازمه او على الاقل لوقف اطلاق النار
والدخول في مفاوضات لكنها لم تنجح بسبب او
لم تنجح يعني كليا بسبب
التعنت الذي ابداه الطرفان خاصه
قياده الجيش السوداني
وهذا ادى الى
موت هذه المبادرات او تحقيقها جزءا بسيطا
من النجاح يتعلق
بالهودنات الانسانيه القصيره التي تمت
واستفاده منها
الكثيرون من السودانيين فيما يتعلق
بمبادره القاهره هي حاولت القاهره هذه
المره ان تتغلب على عيوب المبادرات
السابقه
وان تجمع دول جوار السودان معا كلها لكي
تتفق على حل شامل طبعا بموافقه الطرفين
السودانيين
المتحاربين هذا الحل يتمثل اولا في وقف
اطلاق النار على الاقل حتى لمده ثلاثه
اشهر
والدخول في مفاوضات والا تسمح اي دوله من
الدول الجوار لاطراف اخرى سواء ميليشيات
او ارهابيين او جماعات متطرفه بالدخول الى
السودان او مسانده اي طرف من الاطراف والا
تساند هذه الدول او منها اي طرف من اطراف
الازمه وايضا ان تسهل عمليات المساعدات
الانسانيه
للاجئين الذين فروا اليها وان تساعد على
التهدئه لوقف طوفان المهاجرين اليها كل
هذه الامور تبلورت في النهايه على اتفاق
بين الاطراف المجتمعه هذا الاتفاق يعني
ابرز ما فيه هو الحفاظ على سياده السودان
وعدم التدخل في شؤونه سواء بشكل فردي او
جماعي من الاتحاد الافريقي او اي جاد وهذا
رد على محاوله البعض
[موسيقى]
دعوه قوات الاحتياطي الخاصه بدول شرق
افريقيا للتدخل في السودان وهذا امر خطير
جدا اذا لم يتم الموافقه عليه من جانب
الطرفين المتحاربين ويمكن ان تحدث معارك
بين القوات التي ستدخل
قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع من ناحيه
اخرى كما انه
لا يمكن نشر مثل هذه القوات الا بموافقه
مجلس الامن وفقا للماده 42 من ميثاق الامم
المتحده من الفصل السابع من ميثاق الامم
المتحده اذا هذه
قمه القاهره اغلقت الطريق امام هذا التدخل
طالما انه لم يحظى بموافقه الطرفين
المتحاربين الامر الاخر هو تشكيل لجنه
وزاريه لمتابعه تجتمع في تشاد اول مره
تحاول وضع
خطه تنفيذيه لمقررات القاهره
هذه الخطه
يمكن ان تحدث
وتكون مقنعه ويمكن ان
يعجب بعض بندها هذا الطرف او زاد وبالتالي
يمكن لهذا الطرف او ذاك ان يقتل هذه الخطه
في مهدها وبالتالي يعني تصبح المبادره
المصريه او المبادره دول الجوار تصبح لا
قدر الله في عداد المبادرات الغير الموفقه
مثل المبادرات السابقه لكن في النهايه
الاستاذ
الكاتب والبحث السياسي السوداني من باريس
استاذ محمد
الاطراف المختلفه التي تعاطت مع هذا
الصراع داخل السودان كانت لها مواقف ورؤى
ومصالح متباينه الى حد كبير لكن لاحظنا
انها كلها تقريبا رحبت بمخرجات قمه دول
الجوار التي انعقدت في القاهره ما الذي ما
الجديد الذي جاء من قمه القاهره سبب هذا
الترحيب
في البدايه التحيه لكل الضيوفك الكرام
والمشاهدين الاقارب بلا شك مبادره دوري
السودان التي انعقدت بالقاهره اليوم لم
تاتي في في طياره او في ثنايا الكثير من
النقاط التي يعني مختلفه تماما عن سواء
كان المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه او
مبادره الدول الايجار او حتى مبادره
الاتحاد الافريقي التي صدرت من مجلس السلم
والامن الافريقي وما الى ذلك وانما تاتي
في اطار محاوله
تبني وجهه نظر حديث او خطوط عريضه هي محل
الاجماع لدى كل القوه قوه قوه الجوار
وكذلك القوه الاقليميه والدوله وبما في
ذلك طرفيه الصراع الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع لكن انا في تقدير الان التحدي
بيكمل في الاجتماع الوزاري الذي سينعقد
فيه وهو من شانه وضع الخطوط العريضه وكذلك
ملامح المشروعه والتصور الذي يتم تقديمه
من قبل
السودان لطرفيه الازمه بمعنى هل هذا
التصور ياتي في اطار
المقاربه او التوصيف الحكومي الى الازمه
بانه محرز هو انقلاب من قبل القوى عسكريه
كانت تتبع للجيش السوداني ارادت ان تغير
السلطه عن طريق القوه ام سيكون هنالك
مقاربه اشبه بتوظيف الدعم السريعي ان
هنالك محاوله لانقضاء على مسار الانتقال
المدني الديمقراطي في السودان من قبل
المؤسسه العسكريه او ستطرح مبادره تتبنى
وجهه نظريه الصرع ومن شانها هذه المبادره
تجد القبول من طرفي الصرع لكن انا في
تقدير الان التحدي اذا استطاعت هذه الدول
في في الحديث بشكل مباشر بان ينبغي ان
تكون هنالك عمليات مستعجله تتحدث بشكل
واضح عن قيود زمنيه ومناقشه الاسباب التي
اسهمت بشكل مباشر في اندلاء هذه الحرب وهي
القيود الزمنيه المرتبطه بدمج الجيش الدعم
السريع عذرا في الجيش السوداني
عن ذلك قضيه القياده والسيطره لمن تقول
القياده والسيطره هل تكون المؤسسه
العسكريه ممثله في القائد العام ام رئيس
الوزراء الذي يتم اختياره بالتوافق هنالك
قضيه اخرى ايضا مهمه وهو مصيره الجرائم
والانتهاكات التي ارتكبت طوال هذه الفتره
وقبل ذلك ينبغي ان تناقش جزئيه مهمه جدا
وهي ان تكون هنالك نقاط
لتجمع قوات الدعم السريعه الان المنتشره
في الاحياء وكذلك في المؤسسات الحكوميه
حتى تصيب هذه القرارات او هذه الجزئيات
بعوده الحياه وكذلك تسهم بشكل مباشر في
تدفق المساعدات الانسانيه وهذه الجزيئات
التي
نستطيع ان نقول لم تنجح المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه في الحديث عنها بشكل مباشر
وانما كانت تعتمد فقط على فكره ان تكون
هنالك رقابه او اجسام ترغب من الجهه التي
تخترق باطلاق النار استاذ محمد العروسي
الدول الجوار عبرت في اكثر من مرحله من
مراحل هذا الصراع عن مبادرات في اتخذت
اثوابا او خرجت من عباءه مؤسسات مثل
الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد وغيرها بعض هذه
المبادرات لم تلقى ترحيبا من طرفي الصراع
بل وصفت احيانا بانها مبادره الاحتلال
السودان وتمزيقه وتقسيمه هل اغلقت قمه
القاهره هذا الباب نهائيا مس التدخل من
الخارج عسكريا وسياسيا بشكل مباشر في
الازمه الدائره في السودان الان
شكرا على الاستضافه والتحيه لكم ولضيوفكم
الكرامه للساده المشاهدين اولا تجدر
الاشاره الى ان هذا الدور الذي يعني هو
منوط بدول جوار السودان هو دور متمم او
مكمل لهذه الادوار المنوطه بالايجاد وكذلك
الاتحاد الافريقي ففي الاتحاد الافريقي
نجد ان هناك تقاسم لمناطق النفوذ او لبعض
القرارات تقاسم يعني هناك السودان يتبع
لبعض
الكيانات في الاتحاد الافريقي ومن اختصاص
الايجاد فهذه النقطه هي التي ربما خفيت
على الكثيرين مما جعلهم يفسرون ان هذه
المباراه التي يدلي بها يبادر بها الاتحاد
الافريقي وكذلك بعض الساسه الافارقه بانها
مبادرات احتلال وتقسيم للسودان نحن نسال
مثلا ماذا تستفيد اثيوبيا وهي صانعه
السلام وال
حرفيا وفعليا مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي
مبادره الايجاد الذي كان سببا في علاج
المشكله بين جنوب السودان والاتفاقيات
التي تلف ذلك حتى استقر السوداء حتى استقر
الوضع في السودان انا ذاك فهناك يعني ربما
احتقان من غير معرفه السبب ومن غير هذه
ربما التبريرات المنطقيه التي نرجوها فمن
كان يعترض ويحاول ان يصدر اللغه الشعبويه
العاطفيه التي يتحدث فيها ويقول انزعها
بنفسك ومن غيرها من هذه الشعارات الرنانه
نعتقد بان هؤلاء ربما لم يفهموا مضمون هذه
المبادرات فماذا تستفيد اثيوبيا حينما
تنزع الاسلحه او تقوم بحظر الطيران وهذا
الامر بالمناسبه يعني لا يمكن الا ان
يوافق عليه السودانيون كيف تقوم يعني
مبادره من قبل الاتحاد الافريقي
تتضمن احتلالا لدوله الافريق عضوه فاعله
ومؤثره في هذا الكيان الافريقي هذا امر
غير منطقي وانما هو سوء فهم للموقف
السياسي من قبل اثيوبيا والمبادرين بهذه
المبادرات التي لم يكنها ربما لم يكن
الموقف الاثيوبي موفقين في اختيار الخطوات
والكلمات المعبره عنه يعني
ما الذي يمكن ان يفهمه الجانب السوداني
المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه من مساله حظر
الطيران مثلا فوق الاراضي السودانيه
يجب ان يفهم بانها اله فتاقه
تخشى دول الجوار من انها تبيد الاخضر
واليابس كما يحدث الان منذ اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر يجب ان يعلموا جميعا بان بان اثيوبيا
عندما تقوم او الاتحاد الافريقي عندما
يبادرون بهذه المبادره ليس لهم هم الا
مصلحه السودان وهذا الامر لا يعد اختراقا
او تدخل في شؤون السودان الداخليه فلماذا
نكون يعني متدخلين حينما نطرح اراء نحفظ
بها دماء السودانيين العزيزه علينا ايضا
فهذه المبادره ينبغي
دعني اشرك مجددا الاستاذ محمد تورشين من
باريس هل يعني اذا كان الوضع بهذه الصوره
بسبب الحساسيه الزائده التي كانت تجري على
السنه المسؤولين السودانيه
انا في تقدير يعني ينبغي ان نسمي الاشياء
باسمائها يعني وحتى نكون اكثر دقه واكثر
موضوعيه او المشاهد هو بحاجه الى هذه
المعلومات على المدى الاستراتيجي والدوله
الاثيوبيه بغض النظر اذا كان الحاكم باحمد
او اي حاكم اخر من مصلحه اثيوبيا ان يكون
السودان دوله ضعيفه هشه تعاني من
الاضطرابات الداخليه وعدم الاستقرار لماذا
لانها بحاجه لمعالجه الانفجار الديموغرافي
الذي تعاني منه اثيوبيا والاستفاده من
الاراضي الخصمه في منطقه الفشكه وراينا
تماما عندما بدات القوات المسلحه
السودانيه باستعاده الاعراض المحتله من
قبل اسيبه في منطقه كان هذا الامر مزعجا
جدا للسلطات الاثيوبيه ممثله في حكومه ابي
احمد فضلا عن ذلك هنالك ايضا مصالح اخرى
او وجود السودان دور لا ضعيفه ومنهار
وتعاني من الاضطرابات سيؤثر بشكل سلبي جدا
في موقف السودان اذا قضيه صدرنا هذا
وبالتالي سيدعم موقف اثيوبيا فيما يتعلق
بالاستمرار مشروعها والملا الرابع والخامس
واستكمال المشروع فضلا عن ذلك هنالك بعض
العلاقات حتى والاستثمارات الاقتصاديه
التي نراها تماما بعض
بين الرجال الاعمال السوداني اسامه داوود
وكذلك حكومه اثيوبيا ومعلومه انه ابي احمد
لديه علاقات جيده لما اسامه داوود بل في
المعارك الاخيره التي حدثت في الفجره ارسل
هذا اسامه داوود كمفاوضا على الحكومه
الاثيوبيه او في اطار المباحثات التي
استضافتها ابو ظبي فبالتالي اثيوبيا في
نهايه المطاف واحده من دول كثيره تمثل
الجوار السوداني استاذ عطيه عيسوي ما هي
المصالح الاستراتيجيه
لهذه الدول دول جوار السودان التي يمكن ان
يؤدي التضارب بينها الى استمرار او اطاله
امد هذا الصراع في السودان
المصالح هناك مصالح استراتيجيه طبعا
يعني في مصلحه الجميع في مقدمتها وقف
الصراع لوقف تدفق اللاجئين وما قد يحدث
بسببه من تسلل عناصر ارهابيه وعناصر تذاع
زي الامن وتدخل اطراف خارجيه الى جانب هذا
الطرف او زاد من
منظمه مثل بجنر الروسيه من داخل اراضي
تشاد او من داخل افريقيا الوسطى وايضا
ميليشيات او منظمات اخرى ترى ان هذا الطرف
او ذاتي يحقق لها هدفها وبالتالي يجب ان
يعني تنضم اليه وتسانده طيب
تدفق اللاجئين على دول الجوار وهذه من حق
دول الجوار ان يكون لديها هواجس منها اكثر
الدول تقريبا التي استقبلت لاجئين من
السودان هو الدوله المصريه وهي الدوله
المصريه ورغم ذلك حاضيه موقف القاهره طول
فصول هذا الصراع برضا وترحيب تقريبا من
المؤس سه العسكريه السودانيه ما تفسير ذلك
ما الذي لم يحظى بترحيب المؤسسه العسكريه
اقول ان مصر من اكثر البلدان التي استقبلت
لاجئين جراء الصراع داخل السودان ورغم ذلك
ورغم انك تحدثت عن انها هذا هاجس لدى دول
الجوار رغم هذا كان الموقف المصري دائما
محل ترحيب من قبل المؤسسه العسكريه
الرسميه في السودان
طبعا هذا ربما يفهمه البعض على انه انحياز
للمؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه ضد الطرف
الاخر لكن مصر وقفت على الحياد بين
الطرفين في منذ البدايه وحاولت
الوساطه بينهما سواء منفرده او مع دول
اخرى مثل قطر ومثل الامارات ومثل السعوديه
ومثل جنوب السودان
لوقف الحرب والجلوس الى مائده التفاوض لكن
في رايي رايي وليس راي الدوله راي كصحفي
هو انه اذا انتهى الامر الى
ضروره الاختيار ما بين هذا الطرف او ذاك
سيتعين
الاختيار
للطرف الذي يمثل الشرعيه في السودان هذا
الطرف هو المؤسسه العسكريه المعترف بها
دوليا للسودان والمعترف بها الشعب
السوداني نفسه وليس مجرد
وليس الطرف الاخر الذي هو فرع من فروع
المؤسسه العسكريه طيب على النقيب من هذا
الموقف للمؤسسه على النقيض من هذا الموقف
استاذ محمد العروسي الموقف الاثيوبي لم
يكن يحظى لها موقف اثيوبيا ولا موقف كينيا
لم يكن يحظى بترحيب من قبل المؤسسه
العسكريه والمؤسسه الرسميه في السودان ما
المصالح الاستراتيجيه
لاثيوبيا في هذه
الازمه
وما ردكم على ما تفضل به ضيفنا من السودان
من ان اثيوبيا بقياده حكومه ابي احمد ترغب
دائما في السودان ضعيف
نعم اقول انه تحليل خاطئ وكذلك مؤدلج يحكي
عاطفه بانحيازه للموقف او لمواقف القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ونحترم ذلك فيما لو كان
الاتهام لاثيوبيا واقعيا بينما انت تتهم
اثيوبيا لتدافع عن هذه المؤسسه العسكريه
اثيوبيا تراها بانها مؤسسه عسكريه تجدر
الحفاظ عليها بما يمكننا من قوات وكذلك من
امكانيات نظرا لاهميه السودان الاستراتيجي
مصالحنا الاستراتيجيه هو في السلام الذي
ينعم به تنعم به دول الجوار واولها
السودان ذلك الجار الشقيق الذي نكل له كل
تقدير واحترام ونحن لسنا بصدد توضيح هذه
المسائل فكلها يعني كلها تبدو للعيان
حينما نجد ان رئيس الوزراء فخامه الدكتوره
به احمد هو صانع السلام في السودان بهذه
المبادره التي
حكى عنها السودانيون ولا زالوا يحكون عنها
حتى اليوم كما ان اثيوبيا لها مواقف كبيره
ثم حتى في هذه الازمه مبادراتها
لمحمد طرشين باختصار لو تكرمت في تقديرك
ما
التداعيات التي يمكن ان تحدث على مسار
الصراع في السودان بعد مخرجات قمه دول
الجوار السودان في القاهره
في تقدير الان الناظر الى تصريح حتى طرفيه
السرعه الى الجيش السوداني وكذلك مؤسسه
السياده اصدرت بيان رحبت فيه بهذه
المخرجات وكذلك الدعم السريع لكن انا في
تقدير التحدي الان الدعم السريع راغب كذلك
القوه السياسيه الحاضنه التي يعني تتحرك
ايضا خلفي راغبه في ان يكون هنالك وضع
جديد عن طريق المباحثات باعتبار الحرب هي
ليست غايه انما هدف لتحقيق غايه وانا في
تقدير الغايه تتمثل في ان يكون هنالك جيش
واحد لدرجه دعم السريع كلها الحركات
المسلحه وان تكون هنالك فتره انتقاليه
قصيره وجمعيه تشريعيه تناقش القضايا
الدستوريه والقانونيه ومن بعد الشروع في
انتخابات عامه فانا في تقديري اذا
المبادره جابت على هذه الاسئله الجوهريه
والمهمه وقدمت تصور في هذا الاطار يتم من
خلاله دمج الدعم السريع في فتره وجيزه فلا
تتجاوز العام وكذلك تكون هنالك حكومه
في اقل من دقيقه لو تكرمت هل ترى امكانيه
واقعيه لتحقيق ما ذهب اليه ضيف نا من
باريس
اعتقد انه يمكن ذلك اذا اخلص الطرفان
النيه الطرفان المتحاربان وتعاونت معهما
دول الجوار هناك رد فعل جيد جدا
مبدئي من الجيش بانه مستعد للوقف اطلاق
النار اذا التزم الدعم السريع
بالعدم الاعتداء وفقا لوصف على مساكن
المواطنين وعلى المنشات المدنيه وهذا تطور
يحدث لاول مره في اعتقادي وهو اذا اذا
كانوا بالفعل صادقين في هذا يمكن ان يكون
مدخلا
للبدايه التوصل الى حل ووقف اطلاق النار
والجلوس الى مائده التفاوض اما اذا كانت
تصريحات للاستهلاك الاعلامي اعتقد ان
الامور لن تتغير على الارض الاستاذ عطيه
عيسوي الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه كان
معنا من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لك واشكرك
كذلك ضيفين من فارس محمد طرشين الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني ومن الذي سبابا
الاستاذ محمد الع روسي عضو البرلمان
الفيدرالي الاثيوبي
ا مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج
[موسيقى]